seulement 12,98 % pour le candidat
socialiste multiplication des listes à
gauche et dynamique nationale ont eu
raison des ambitions de tristan jacques
dans la 2e circonscription des yvelines
maire-adjoint de magny les hameaux où il
ne devance son adversaire de droite que
de 3%
il avait pourtant tenté de montrer ses
différences avec la politique du
gouvernement
insuffisant pour une candidature commune
avec europe ecologie les verts
l'une des seules formations en
progression par rapport à 2012 moi j'ai
continué à faire du porte à porte tous
les jours je vais continuer ma temps
déjà elle avait droit comme je n'ai
peut-être pas la garde de leur fille
chantier plus grande part le ps a divisé
son nom de loi par quatre les
républicains par deux et finalement on
est les seuls en ondes en nombre
d'électeurs qui a qui nous maintenant on
a à peine baissé
donc c'est une super nouvelle on donnera
pas de consigne de vote puisque les
électeurs sont libres de leur choix ça
s'appelle la démocratie et c'est très
bien comme ça
sauf surprise c'est donc pascal thévenot
maire de vélizy soutenu par les
électeurs de sa commune qui devrait
l'emporter sur l'ensemble de la
circonscription il totalise plus de 46%
ma campagne s'arrête pas quel que soit
même si on peut imaginer que
il ya de grandes chances que j'arrive à
l'emporter dimanche prochain mais c'est
ma nature et puis j'ai été à bonne école
avec valérie pécresse au dessus une
élection ça se gagne que le soir à 20
heures
donc là je serai encore sur les marchés
je crois encore en porte à porte
j'ai encore des équipes dans toutes les
gares et j'enrage les accompagnera tous
les matins un duel droite gauche pour le
second tour programmé dimanche qui
masque le résultat du front national
quatrième devancé par benjamin lacombe
issu du mouvement yvelines pour tous
la liste manif pour tous en réalité est
un copier coller de notre programme ils
sont également contre contre
l'immigration massive ils sont pour la
seule chaîne guen ils sont pour le débat
sur l'euro on voit que nos idées sont
très présentes maintenant leur présence
à eux a permis justement au ps de se
maintenir et de rester au second tour de
cette élection on retiendra surtout la
faible participation à peine 30 % des
électeurs se sont rendus aux urnes